>>Romain Guy: Good afternoon everyone. And
welcome to the world of ListView.
My name is Romain Guy, and I'm an android
engineer at Google.
I work on the UI toolkit and a few other things
and joining me today is Adam Powell, he's
also an engineer at Google. He works also
on the UI toolkit if you've ever been mad
at ListView, it's probably my fault and now
his fault So, if you have things to tell us
at the end of the session, come talk to us
and you can do whatever you want to us.
We have a Google Wave where you can share
notes during the presentation. You can also
ask questions. You can vote on the questions
asked eight-by other people. You can also
download the questions that you think are
stupid. And here is the URL. Once you will
be able to see it, so try to write it down.
If you don't have the time to write it down
right now, we will put the slide up at the
end of the session, and you can also go to
the Google I/O Web site and link to that Wave.
And we will also take live questions, of course.
So how many of you have ever used ListView
as a developer in an Android application?
Raise your hand. That's scary and good.
How many of you have found ListView to be
difficult to use?
You are the ones who are lying.
And how many of you have swore at least during
the past few days. Yeah, I see some hands.
That's good, that's good. That means you are
doing some complex stuff with it.
For those of you who have never used ListView,
it's a pretty common widget on Android. It's
used I think in almost every application we
ship. And you can see an example here on the
slide on the left side, that's one of our
API demos. So it just stacks widgets vertically.
Most of the time ListView shows simple text,
sometimes we have icon and text, but you can
do very, very complex ListViews.
Before we shipped Android 1.0 we had a version
of Gmail where when you opened an email we
were using a ListView made of Web views to
display conversation.
We stopped doing that because it works, but
it's not that great to use.
But if you really want to do something really
crazy, you can.
And of course you can also do some very complex
things with ListView. So on the right side
you see an example of an app I wrote that
customizes the ListView. It's a grid view,
which is very similar, and you can customize
the background, you can customize the selection,
you can have very complex items inside each
row.
And just for the side note, everything we
are going to talk about today applies to ListView
but also applies to grid view there are a
couple of things that are specific to ListView
but pretty much be everything applies to grid
view as well.
So if you ever need a grid view, you can refer
to this talk, you can refer to the slides
and everything will be the same.
Here is our agenda for this session. We are
going to talk about adapters and virtualization.
We are going to talk about item properties,
headers and footers, selectors, and then we
are going to finish the talk with a few other
features and what you should never ever ever
do with a ListView. And I will ask during
the last slides who amongst the audience is
doing the things you should never do, and
I will be really mad at you.
Adam is going to start with adapters.
>>Adam Powell: Okay.
So the problem present here is dealing with
large data sets. Specifically presenting those
large data sets.
If you have 10,000 items available to you,
how do you get that on screen so that the
user can peruse them, so that you can get
through them relatively quickly?
The two big challenges for dealing with that
is memory and performance. You don't want
to attach 10,000 views into your view hierarchy.
Views are fairly heavyweight objects in that
sense. And you want to be able to fling through
them quickly. People expect to be able to
navigate things quickly on touch screen devices
especially.
So the solution we have implemented in ListView
is that we populate views on demand. So we
only bring up new views as they are actually
needed. Nothing actually gets added to the
view hierarchy that isn't going to be displayed
on screen.
Secondly, we recycle those views.
So we reuse the views that we have already
created and just fill in new content as they
come through.
This helps us address a lot of the performance
issues that come up when you are cycling through
things very quickly, when you are flinging
through a very long list.
So a little bit of terminology to start off
with. Just because there's a lot of different
ways to refer to data when you are working
with a ListView.
When we talk about an index, we are talking
about child views within the view group in
the hierarchy.
So if you are calling get child at to go ahead
and fetch a view that's there, that's when
we are talking about indices.
When we are talking about position, we are
talking about a position of an element within
your adapter.
And finally, when we talk about IDs, each
item within an adapter can have a unique identifier
that refers to the value of the data stored
there. So if things start shuffling around,
you perform insertions or deletions on the
data that's backing your adapter, then this
lets us do a few extra tricks when you have
StableIDs.
When you tell the ListView that you have StableIDs
by returning true from your adapter's has
StableIDs function, then we are able to perform
a few extra tricks that just makes the presentation
a little bit nicer when a lot of elements
get added or removed. We can try and keep
the data relatively stable on screen.
>>Romain Guy: And understanding what the index
position and ID do is very important because
I have got to admit, the documentation of
ListView is somewhat lacking, to remain polite,
and it's entirely our fault. We are very sorry.
But we have been very careful with respect
to the naming of our parameters.
So whenever you see a method that talks about
position or you see a parameter of a method
that's called index, you know it's currently
that it's going to be those meanings. Everything
is pretty good in that regard.
>>Adam Powell: Definitely.
So the meat of your adapter is going to be
the get view method. This is what takes your
data from your data source, whatever that
may be, whether it be something you are fetching
from a network, something from a database
that's local. It doesn't matter what it is.
Get view gives you full presentation control
over your data. You can return any arbitrary
view, and then that becomes your element within
the ListView.
So within get view, we offer a lot of opportunities
to optimize this entire process. And kind
of to go along with that, because we make
assumptions in order to make these optimizations,
there's a lot of opportunity to shoot yourself
in the foot.
And I'm sure that some of you have come across
one or more of these before. You know, why
can't I click on this element that's a child
far down in this particular list item?
We'll get into some of that. We will get into
why. And specifically, we'll get into the
fairly narrow subset of things that you sudden
be doing within get view.
So ListView tries to be smart. As you can
see, it's fairly easy to outsmart here and
there, but through get view, we pass in an
extra view parameter called convert view.
We talked about how ListView ends up reusing
some of these views as you are flinging through
data quickly. Convert view is how it makes
that happen.
ListView will keep track of all the extra
views that are moving off screen and then
give you one back to fill out with your existing
data. This is the convert view parameter that
we saw on this slide here.
So this will automatically match up item types
for you as well. If you have multiple types
of different data within your adapter, then
convert view will always be the correct type
as long as you tell ListView what type each
position in your adapter is. And we will get
to that in a little bit as well.
So if a convert view parameter, pass to your
get view is not null, please reuse it. It's
going to help the performance of your application
quite a bit.
>>Romain Guy: So there are different ways
to implement the get view method. We are going
to see three of those different methods. There
is the slow way, the correct way and the fast
way.
So first of all, look at this slide really
quickly and please raise your hand, and that's
okay, don't be ashamed, if you have ever written
a get view method like this. Some of you have
done it. Okay, at least there is someone honest
in the room.
>>Adam Powell: There are a few over here,
too.
>>Romain Guy: This is the native way you would
implement get view. You would create a new
view every time get view is invoked.
So you can see here at line number 2, we are
inflating a view from XML. This is a very
expensive preparation. We have to parse the
XML, and even though this is highly optimized
on Android, it still takes quite a bit of
time. We have to initialize the view, we have
to allocate the memory, and it can be very
costly when the view is made of subviews.
So here, for instance, the view inflating
in that example is contains an image view
and a text view.
Once we have created it in line three and
four we just bind some data to those two views.
So we put some text in the text view, an image
on the image view, and then we return the
view we have created.
The big problem with that is if the user is
flinging the list and is trying to scroll
through thousands of items, then we are going
to create thousands of those views which is
going to take a lot of memory.
To give you an idea, a view on Android costs
about one or two kilobytes of RAM. So if you
have a thousand views, that's already a meg
of RAM that you are wasting, which means that
the garbage collector is going to kick in
and it's going to stop your UI thread. It's
going to make the animation stutter and the
user will be really pissed at your application.
And don't believe that lists of thousands
of items are rare, because, for instance,
I know many people who have thousands of contacts
in their application -- in their address book,
and it's very easy to do when your e-mail
application is set up to create contacts automatically
whenever you reply to an e-mail.
So to fix this, the convention, you just have
to use the convert view. So simply check whether
or not the convert view is null. If it's null,
then you have to create a new view. You can
inflate from XML. You can create the view
programmatically. You do whatever you want,
but you have to create a new view.
In the other case, if the convert view is
already available, just reuse it.
Like we said, we guarantee that the convert
view is the type of view that you want, so
you know you are going to have your text view,
you know you are going to have your image
view and this is going to be much faster.
Basically, with this method, you are going
to allocate only the number of views you need
to fill the screen. Sometimes it's going to
allocate like one or two more, but most of
the time it's going to be only like seven
or eight views on a Nexus One, for instance.
So it's very little.
There's another technique to make that implement
go faster. It's a pattern that we call the
view holder that we developed on the Android
team just before 1.0 because we were running
into performance issues, especially with address
books full of thousands of contacts.
So the idea is that you are going to create
a small data structure in your application
that is going to hold data that's static for
each given row of the list.
So in that example, for each item in the list,
we are doing a find you by ID to find a text
view and an image view in lines five and six.
So why should we bother doing it thousands
and thousands of times as we scroll through
a big list. So instead we are just going to
hold the things once and forever in this little
class called the view holder. So you can create
it wherever you want. Try to make that class
static so you don't link the enclosing instance.
And this is what the code looks like when
you use the view holder.
So the only difference is when you create
a new view when the convert view is null,
you create your instance of the view holder,
you do the work of finding the children of
the view. So here we find the text view and
the image view, so that's line 5 to 9. And
then you can set the holder as the tag for
the view.
So the tag is just a random object. It can
be anything you want that you can put on a
view.
And we use the tag facility here to store
extra data.
When you have a convert view that's passed
to you by this view, you simply get the tag.
You get it as a view holder, and then if you
like, at line 16 and 17 you can see we access
the text view and image view directly. So
we save the cost of doing the find view.
This is a very simple example, but in some
applications you can store even more data
in there. You can store char arrays to do
database queries to allocating new arrays
of characters every time do you a query.
And this is a comparison of the preference
of the three methods. So would we took those
numbers using the Froyo build of Android that
you guys don't have yet. This is running with
a fast CPU because we are on a Nexus One,
and we created a list of 10,000 items. Each
item is a linear layer that contains an image
and a text view. With the dumb implementation
of get view we get about 20 frames per second.
When we implement get view correctly by reusing
the convert view, we go up to 50 frames per
second. And finally when we use the view holder
we go up to 55 frames per second.
To give you an idea on the Nexus One, the
maximum number of frames per second you can
get is 60. So when you take into account the
overhead of just redrawing the view hierarchy,
issuing all the commands, binding the views,
reading the bitmap, stuff like that. This
is pretty much as fast as you can go inside
an adapter.
So if you can reach those numbers inside your
application, you are good to go.
If you are on the left side, then keep working.
>>Adam Powell: Okay.
So as I mentioned before, there are a lot
of ways to shoot yourself in the foot during
this process. Most of it has to do with trying
to outsmart the way that get view tries to
optimize things for you.
So don't create any sort of local view cache.
Don't try and be smart and say, okay, well,
I know that position one is always going to
be this element, so I am just going to save
this view away in my adapter and always return
this whenever I am asked for position one.
The problem with that is that due to the implementation
of the recycler inside ListView, if you are
not passing back either a new view that was
just created or exactly the convert view instance
that was passed to you, it's going to assume
that anything else that was ever attached
to the ListView is dead. And it's just going
to go ahead and throw it away.
Sometimes this can end up getting reattached
in really strange ways, and it won't always
look like there's a problem at first until
you start observing some very strange behavior.
So don't cache views locally like that, and
don't access the views from the adapter that
way.
Don't change convert view's structure, either.
Just because you have a view coming in, that
doesn't necessarily mean that you need to
be adding and removing extra content from
that view.
That's what the type system is for.
We can actually have convert view pass you
back exactly the type of view that you need
that already has all these other subviews
initialized for you. So just because you have
different types of data within your adapter
doesn't necessarily mean that you need to
try to perform all sorts of manipulations
on convert view when it comes in.
And lastly, don't make assumptions about get
view calls. We have seen developers try to
do things like, okay, get view was just called
for position 5, so I am going to store something
about this particular view instance is position
5, and I am going to cache that someplace.
I am going to -- just so that I can refer
back to that view quickly, whenever data behind
it updates.
The problem with this is that the order of
get view calls isn't guaranteed. So we may
end up calling get view behind the scenes
to go ahead and measure out how big the ListView
can be, and we might do this with a throw-away
convert view that we are passing to you. Again,
for performance reasons.
So the view that you get -- the last view
that you get passed to you for a position
may not actually be the one that ends up on
screen later on.
>>Romain Guy: And, actually, a great example
of making assumptions about the ordering of
the getView calls is something that happened
to us inside the Android team really recently.
The GMail application was making one of these
assumptions.
And so in Froyo, they changed something about
the UI that made them go through a different
code path in ListView.
And suddenly the order of the getView calls
changed.
And every single one of your e-mails in your
inbox looked like the first e-mail of the
inbox.
And that wasn't a bug ListView; that was a
problem in the application, because they were
assuming that they would get you zero, get
you one, get you two, get you three, which
wasn't the case anymore.
To give you any idea, I think we have at least
four or five different ways to perform layout
in ListView, so sometimes we're going to start
by doing the layout from the bottom of the
screen; sometimes we start from the top; sometimes
we start from the middle.
So, again, don't make any assumption about
the order of the calls.
>>Adam Powell: Okay.
So what happens when your data changes?
Whenever your data changes, you need to update
your adapter in some way.
And not only that, but you need to tell ListView
that the adapter was updated.
You do this by calling notify data set changed.
This basically triggers ListView to rescan
your adapter for the views that are onscreen,
repopulate them, deal with any sort of manipulations
in terms of scrolling the lists if there's
fewer data elements in there now or growing
it out if there's more.
If your data set becomes unavailable, for
example, if, like, your backing file gets
deleted, if your network access goes out,
notify data set invalidated will tell us that
there is no more data, it's entirely gone
and we're not going to try and access it anymore.
>>Romain Guy: And we'll talk about it more
later.
But it's very, very important to call notify
data set change.
Most of the bugs I see filed against ListView
usually come from the application not calling
notify data set change correctly.
It has to be called on the UI thread and has
to be called every time you modify your adapter,
especially when you change the number of items
inside the adapter.
And, actually, I don't remember for what release,
it was maybe Donut or Eclair, so 1.6 or 2.0,
we added a new exception in ListView, so it
tries to detect the case when you change the
adapter without telling the ListView.
When that happens, now we crash.
We throw an exception, and we have a very,
very long and detailed message in the log
cat telling you that you're doing something
wrong probably with the thread.
So if you see that message, pay attention
to it.
It's very important that you fix this issue.
>>Adam Powell: We mentioned before that ListView
will handle different view types for you.
A lot of times, you have more than one type
of data that you want to display at once.
Certain list elements you may want to include
images in.
Certain ones may have extended quoted text.
All of these things end up being different
types of data that you want to display within
the same list.
And ListView will help you out with this.
The function get item view type on your adapter
tells ListView what type the view at that
position should be.
So generally, this is -- this is just an integer
parameter that you pass back.
So however many types you have, return that
from getView type count.
And ListView will maintain basically a recycler
for each of these different view types that
you have.
And it will always be ready to hand you back
the correct one when getView gets called.
>>Romain Guy: Something else very important
about the item types, that the number of types
you have, so when you implement the getView
type count method, that number has to be constant
throughout the life cycle of your adapter.
You cannot make that number change.
It's okay if you say that you have ten types
and you actually end up using only two.
It's not going to be -- it's not going to
waste any resources.
But if you change that number, then very,
very bad things will happen in ListView, and
you will see really weird behavior that might
be very (inaudible) from time to time.
So try to figure out what is the maximum number
of types you're going to need and return that
number from the getView type count method.
>>Adam Powell: So what happens when you have
a data source that's really slow?
You're bringing something in over a network,
you're reading a large file, one way or another,
you're not going to be able to keep up with
it on your UI thread and still remain responsive.
So fetching that data can actually happening
anywhere.
You can spin off another thread, send a request
out to the network.
It doesn't matter.
But the important thing to remember is that
you always commit your adapter changes on
the UI thread.
And, once again, make sure you call notify
data set changed.
So any changes have to be reflected on that
UI thread.
>>Romain Guy: And you also have to call notify
data set change in the same UI event where
you commit the changes to the adapter.
You can't change the adapter and then sometime
later send and notify data set change to the
ListView, because in between, there might
be a request for a layout, and then ListView
will have conflicting data.
Then we're going to talk about a couple of
item properties.
So the first one is actually really simple.
It's the ability to disable list items.
If you look at the adapter interface, so when
you create your own adapter, there's a method
that lets you tell ListView whether or not
an item is enabled.
By default, all items are enabled.
And having an enabled item lets you select
it with a track ball, so you will get with
the default theme the orange highlight behind
the item.
It lets you also click the item.
And you can get a nonlist item click event.
In some cases, though, you want to disable
these items.
Disabling items is not necessarily to show
the user that this item is not available.
For instance, it may be a Web server that's
not reachable.
It's also for -- simply to create different
items -- items that have a different visual
appearance.
So here's an example.
This is a market application.
If you look at the green headers in the middle
of the ListView, those are disabled items.
So they make them disabled because they serve
as headers.
So they just indicate different sections of
the list.
Obviously, it wouldn't make sense to be able
to select them with a track ball or to click
on them.
So it's a very simple feature that's used
heavily inside the Android platform, and you
can integrate user bits inside your own navigations.
>>Adam Powell: So sometimes just getting a
click event on a specific list item isn't
enough.
You want the user to be able to make choices
within that list.
You may want that choice to be mutually exclusive.
You can only select one item at a time.
You may want the user to be able to select
multiple items out of a specific list.
So for that, we provide choice mode.
You have single choice mode, which gives you
radio buttons, once again, for mutually exclusive
choices, and you have multiple choice mode
which lets you check a number of items within
the list.
So what happens when you want to get that
checked state back out and read it in another
part of your application?
You can call several methods on ListView.
Get checked item position will return the
position of the item that you've selected
in single-choice mode.
If you're in multiple-choice mode, you can
call get checked item positions, plural, and
that will give you all of the positions that
are currently checked.
But we mentioned before that there is this
concept of stableIDs within an adapter, where
each value within the adapter has an integer
that specifies uniquely that value, no matter
how the position may change due to other deletions
or insertions.
So if you're going to have a lot of deletions
and insertions within your adapter over time
and you're also making choices, then you can
use get checked item IDs to refer to those
items by ID so that the positions don't get
out of alignment with your actual data.
Come on.
There we go.
Here's an example of each one of the choice
modes.
You've probably seen these before in the ring
tone selector.
And in the selector for which labels you want
to splay in GMail.
So this is how it looks by default.
But as always, you're in control of the presentation
through getView.
So you can make these look as fancy as you
like.
>>Romain Guy: Now, something that's very (inaudible)
is how we handle focusable items.
One of the big constraints we have on the
UI is that we need to support track balls
and touch screens.
We decided early on that as soon as we touched
the screen, the focus or the selection goes
away.
That's why we have the choice mode.
You can't just let the user tap an item in
the list and keep the selection on screen.
ListView will fight really hard to make that
not happen.
So something we've done is that, by default,
if you put a focusable item inside the -- if
you have a row that contains a couple of buttons
but the entire row will be selected when you
use the track ball.
The reason is that it will be very awkward
to have track ball navigation that will go
from selecting the whole item to selecting
little items inside the row itself.
So if you want more control over that, if
you want to have selectable -- focusable items
inside the row, you can tell ListView that
you want that to happen.
So if you call set items can focus, and you
pass true, you're telling ListView, now, on
my rows, I don't want the entire row, I want
to select stuff inside the row.
On the left side we have the content application.
You can see there's a focusable item on the
left that's the quick contact action.
But by default, they decided that they didn't
want the user to be able to select that with
the track ball.
So when you use the track ball, you can only
select the entire row, the entire contact.
On the other hand, in the Twitter application,
they use that feature to be able to -- to
let you select the links inside each tweet.
So you won't be able to select the entire
tweet, but you can navigate with the track
ball from link to link.
So we realize that it's a bit awkward and
sometimes it's difficult when you want to
have complex list items that have several
touchable areas.
There are, like, good tutorials and explanations
on various mailing lists and so on on the
Web.
This is something we would like to improve
in the future.
So if you have ideas on how we should do that,
feel free to contact us on the various Android
groups, and we can talk about it.
My current idea is to maybe have a ListView
2 that will support only touch mode and will
be closer to what you see on other platforms.
>>Adam Powell: So it's pretty rare that you
have a list that you just want to show without
context.
Generally, you want to say something to the
user about what this list contains and what
they're supposed to do with it.
So for this, again, we come back to the Twitter
application that was recently released.
As you can see here, we've got several different
items that provide context for what it is
you're looking at.
We have the tweets header up top.
We say that we're looking at tweets by Google
I/O in this case.
But also at the bottom, we have this extra
element that specifies that we're at the end
of the list that and we're loading new content
on demand.
So this is an example of several different
ways of handling headers and footers within
ListView.
If you want to use a fixed header, this is
pretty easy.
All you need to do is place other views either
above or below your ListView.
And you've probably seen layouts quite a bit
like this before.
If you want them to scroll, then things get
a little bit more complex.
But we've done a little bit of the work for
you so that you don't have to worry too much
about it.
Add header view and add footer view both let
you specify a view that will appear at the
very beginning and the very end of all the
other list content in your adapter.
You can put whatever you want in here.
However, the trick to this is that you have
to call these functions before set adapter.
And that might give you a little bit of a
clue as to how this is implemented under the
hood.
Both these functions also take an extra parameter
"is selectable."
This corresponds to whether or not the final
adapter being used will report back to the
list that these items are enabled.
There's a little bit of a naming conflict
about that.
Sorry about it.
It's not the most intuitive thing in the world.
So as you might have guessed, ListView does
this by internally wrapping your adapter inside
another one, and it returns different view
types for the first and last item.
So what you need to be careful of with this
is that you don't make assumptions that if
you do get adapter on your list, that it's
going to be the same object instance that
you passed in to set adapter in the first
place.
>>Romain Guy: We're going to take a look at
the list selectors.
That's what you see when you use the track
ball to navigate around.
This is what you see when you prefer one click
on an item or simply tap the item.
When you tap an item, you will see the selector
appear on screen briefly for, like, 150 milliseconds
or something like that.
You can customize the list selector.
But what's really important to realize, is
that, first of all, the list selector is not
shown in touch mode.
If you select an item with the track ball
then touch with the screen like I mentioned
before, the selection appears.
Also, the selector by default is shown behind
the items.
This can be a problem if your items have custom
backgrounds, a texture or custom color, then
you won't see -- you won't be able to see
the selector.
On the ListView, in XML, there's also an equivalent,
you can use the selector called draw selector
on top.
If you put true, it will be on the top.
If you do that with the default, you won't
be able to see your item, because our selector
will -- that won't work well.
Here we have an application on the market
called color note.
It has a custom color, yellow background.
They've created their own selector, so they've
created a simple orange border.
How they have done that was simply to set
the draw selector on top equals true attribute
on ListView so that we move the selector back
on top of the (inaudible).
Now if you wanted to have a selector that
was a field -- 'cause you can see here that
it's hollow.
So if you still want the orange highlights
but you also wanted to have a custom background
color, you need to do a little more work,
and you will see how to do that in a couple
of slides.
This is the kind of XML that you have to write
to create a list selector.
How many of you have ever created your own
custom selector?
Quite a few.
And I'm sure that you were a bit puzzled at
first on how to make it work.
Basically, the idea is that you create a drawable
that will tell the framework what (inaudible)
so we have a bunch of different states whether
or not the window is the focus, whether or
not the widget is focused, whether or not
the widget is (inaudible) or selected, et
cetera.
As you can see here, usually you have to be
extremely precise about the states.
So if you look at line number 6, we're saying,
okay, if the item is focused and is not enabled
and is pressed, then we're going to use the
drawable in the background is disabled.
So the best you can do is not to write those
from scratch.
Just grab the source code of the Android platform
or I think we have some examples in the API
demos and just copy and paste what we have
and just replace everything with your own
drawables.
There's also one little trick here.
If you look at line number 13, for instance,
we are referring drawable called list selector
background transition.
That's the drawable that animates when you
long click on an item in a list.
It turns from orange to white.
And if you're interested in how to make that
happen, you can just go check out our source
code and you will see how to declare that
kind of animation.
Actually, it's pretty simple.
Now, if your items on the list have a custom
background, custom opaque background like
we just saw have in the screen shot, and you
still want to have an opaque selector that's
from behind, there's a simple trick.
You can use select your drawable and give
it a transparent when it's selected.
Here you can see it's only a few lines of
XML.
And the state selected -- for the selected
state, we use a transparent company which
is the number zero.
And in every other case, we just use whatever
color we decide to use for our item.
So this is a very simple trick, but it lets
you customize your ListView in whole new ways.
So this is a very simple trick but it let's
>>Adam Powell: So coming into a few of the
other features of ListView.
As many of you who have worked with ListView
will probably already know, there's a whole
other grab bag of functionality that's available
for to you use.
So we are going to go through a couple of
those really quickly.
So transcript mode. How many of you have tried
to write anything resembling chat client?
Anyone? Okay, we have a few.
So hopefully you found transcript mode useful.
So this changes the behavior of the list when
the content changes. So when your call notify
data set changed, your list performs another
layout pass. This defines where we are going
to scroll to now that you have new content.
If it's disabled, which our default, then
we don't scroll when anything changes in terms
of your adapter contents.
If you set transcript mode to normal, however,
then if you are at the edge of the list and
new content comes in, then we are going to
go ahead and scroll to the bottom if the last
item is visible.
So this basically makes it such that if you
are in the middle of a chat client and you
are scrolling back in history, and a new message
comes in, you are not going to scroll to the
bottom immediately there. But if you are already
at the bottom and sort of paying attention
to the live stream of things coming in, then
we are going to go ahead and scroll down and
make that last item visible for you.
So if you are doing a chat client, usually
you are also -- You don't want everything
just stacking from the top. That's not usually
the way you view a chat client. So we have
stack from bottom that makes all the elements
as described stack up from the bottom in terms
of like a chat history to sort of match up
with any sort of input field you may have
below it.
So we stack items in reverse order, and we
start with the last item from the adapter.
So your order still stays the same, but we
just sort of traverse it differently. Once
again, this comes down to don't make assumptions
about the order of calls to getView.
So again this is really useful for any sort
of chat client you might be trying to create.
Here is an example of it. You probably have
seen something very similar before.
This is using both transcript mode and stack
from bottom. As you can see, we're building
the list from the bottom, so we have the empty
space at the top rather than down below.
>>Romain Guy: Every list supports a feature
called text filtering. This is a feature that
was extremely useful on the first device,
on the first Android device that came out,
the T-Mobile G1, because it had a keyboard,
and if you have a Droid, you can actually
use that feature pretty easily. On other devices,
you have to bring the soft keyboard by keeping
the menu key pressed to be able to use it.
So what it does is it lets you -- Here is
a screen shot. So for instance, the music
application, if you bring up the keyboard
and you start typing you are going to filter
the content of the list. So we are going to
show you only the items that match whatever
you typed.
And the matching rules depend entirely on
your adapter.
We have some adapters that by default implement
the filter. So for instance cursor adapter
and array adapter have a basic implement of
the filter.
I think in the array adapter, we just do an
equality comparison so if whatever you type
equals what the item contains, then we are
going to show it. Otherwise, it's going to
be removed from the list.
It's very simple to implement yourself if
you have a custom adapter. All you have to
do is implement the filterable interface and
then the get filter method.
From the get filter method, you have to return
a new instance of the filter class. And the
filter class has only two methods. What's
nice about the filtering mechanism in Android
and we do all the hard work for you, so we
handle everything on the background thread.
When users stop typing, we are going to invoke
this method called perform filtering on the
background thread. So you can do whatever
you want in there. It can be very expensive.
It doesn't matter because you are not going
to bog UI.
We are going to pass you as a trust sequence
whatever the user has typed, and then it's
up to you to rebuild a new list of data you
want to display in the ListView.
To display that new set of data, you have
to return a set of filter results. The filter
result is a simple class that contains the
number of items that you want to show after
filtering, and an object. So the object is
whatever you want.
It's only used to be able -- it can be a cursor,
it can be an array, it can be whatever you
need.
So then when you return that filter result,
we are going to invoke the publish results
method on the UI thread and we are going to
give you back the filter results object. And
your job in this method is simply to extract
the data you put in the filter result and
communicate to the UI adapter. This is where
modify the adapter. This is also where you
call notify that asset has changed.
Implementing a filter is pretty simple. It
involves a couple of classes. But again, if
you look at the Android source code and you
look at the code of the array adapter or the
cursor adapter, you will see how we do it
and it's very simple.
Something that's interesting here, if the
number of results is zero, you might want
to call and notify that asset invalidated
to tell ListView that there is no more data
to display.
So now we want to talk about a few issues
that you might encounter with ListView.
How many of you have ever seen that, like
you have a beautiful ListView, a custom background
and you start scrolling and everything is
black?
So a few already. So the other ones have probably
not tried to customize the background of the
ListView.
The reason of that is simply because of an
optimization beef done.
The problem we have with ListView, especially
on low-end devices such as the T-Mobile G1
or even slower devices, is when you scroll
through a lot of items, especially when you
are flinging and you see dozens and dozens
of items go by every second, we do a lot of
blending on screen. And blending is a very
expensive operation. That's because list items
by default are transparent.
So to avoid that, what we do is that we are
trying to figure out what is the color behind
the list. And by default we know what that
color is. It's some kind of black.
So we turn every item into a bitmap, and we
fill the background of that bitmap with the
color that's behind the list.
So once we have done that, we know that the
entire list is going to be opaque so we can
do optimizations like not draw the window
that's behind the list and avoid the blending
code path in our 2D library, which happened
to be slower than the nonbinding code path.
And actually, that optimization happens as
soon as you touch the screen. As soon as your
finger comes into contact with the screen,
it will turn all the items on the screen into
bitmaps.
So the solution to that issue is simply to
specify the cache color hint. This is an indication
for ListView about the background color. So
if you specify the color zero, like in the
first line of the solution here, you are telling
ListView, okay, I don't have a solid background.
I might have a texture or a complex background.
Please don't do any optimization. So then
we are going to go through a slower code path
but at least you will be able to see everything.
If you remember, one of the first slides when
I showed you this app I wrote that had a wooden
texture, this is what I have done. I disabled
the cache color hint.
If you have a solid background color and you
know what is that background color -- for
instance, you are writing an application that
is green in the background -- you can simply
specify that color and then you are going
to get the optimization of ListView and you
are going to get the correct result.
>>Adam Powell: So how many of you have been
flinging through a list before and seen that
the scrollbar along the side of the screen
changes size?
Yes? Okay.
>>Romain Guy: This is what you call the snake.
>>Adam Powell: Right, the snake effect.
So the reason why this happens is, again,
because we're only drawing as many views as
we need on screen. And when views have vastly
differing heights, being able to measure that
such that we can estimate how much more space
is left to scroll through across the rest
of the adapter becomes a really difficult
problem. It's the sort of thing we have to
get some sort of approximation fast, and that's
why you end up seeing the scrollbar changing
size.
So if you don't like this effect, if this
is something that really sort of detracts
from your app, then you can go ahead and set
smooth scrollbar equals false on your list.
What this will do is it tells ListView don't
even try to bother measuring heights of items
to give an estimate of how much scroll space
is left. Instead, just use your current position
in terms of what items are on screen.
This will make it a little bit chunkier if
you have small data sets, but across very
large data sets, this will really smooth out
how the list looks in terms of scrollbars.
>>Romain Guy: Another solution is also just
to remove the scrollbar.
Okay. So this is something I have seen many
times, and every time I see it I start swearing
in front of my screen and then Joe hates me
because he sits next to me.
This is when you set the la layout height
of a view in XML to wrap content. So have
you ever done that? That's okay, I won't be
mad at you. Just raise your hands. Okay. I
like when people admit their errors.
The problem with wrap content is ListView
is virtualized. So ListView can have two items
but it can have millions of items. So when
it tells us wrap contents it tells us I want
ListView to be as big as it its content. Should
we go through the million items and measure
them? That would probably not be a very good
idea.
And because so many people are requesting
that or are trying do it, we made it work
without making it work.
So if you set the height of your ListView
to wrap content we are going to measure the
first three items of your list.
And actually a lot of people are confused
by that behavior because sometimes I see messages
on our groups saying, hey, when I put log
statements in the getView method, I see getView
is requesting items number zero, one, two,
and then zero, one, two, three, four, five
again. And they don't understand why. And
that's the reason. Because during the layout
we are going to ask the adapter for the first
three items, we are going to measure them,
put them in the recycler and then when we
need the real items we are going to ask for
these items again.
It is expensive, especially if you have very
complex items in your ListView. If you are
crazy and put Web items inside your list then
it will take a lot of time for the ListView
to measure itself. And a lot of times that
is really not what you want.
So either avoid it, either use fill parent
as the height of your ListView or if you are
in a linear layout, you can set the height
to zero and you can use the layout weight
to tell the list to fill your remaining available
space. I was going to also say the height
view leads you to a fixed amount. Like you
can say 200 DIP's to use 200 pixels on the
G1.
>>Adam Powell: How many people have wanted
to do this before? A ListView inside of a
scroll view? Don't be shy. Hands up.
So what happens here? A scroll view scrolls,
a ListView scrolls. Which one should scroll
when you start moving? We actually got a moderator
for this over the weekend for this session
already asking if we could add an element
-- or an attribute to ListView to say can
I make my ListView scrollable equals false
so that I can put it inside a scrollView and
just let the scrollView take care of it? The
quick answer is no, and the reason for that
is once again a ListView can have tens of
thousands possibly even millions of items
inside of it and the correct answer in that
case is almost never to open up that many
views, throw them all into a scrollView and
just let the system die trying to chug along
processing all of that.
So generally, this is where any engineer asks
the question, okay, what is it that you are
trying to do? And generally the answer to
that is, well, I want to have something special,
either above or below my list, but I want
to have mostly just my list content through
this view.
So for that, we would really like to point
you towards the existing header and footer
features that already exist.
If you have a layout that you want to put
above or below a list and still have the entire
thing scroll, you can go ahead and sit that
as a list header or footer.
>>Romain Guy: And by the way, when we tell
you to not put the ListView inside the scrollView,
don't put the scrollView inside the ListView.
>>Adam Powell: Yeah, that, too.
>>Romain Guy: Yeah, so we mentioned that before
in the talk at the beginning, but we really
want to insist on that point, like do not
try to cache views inside your adapter. I
have seen that done way too many times.
There are various reasons why people try to
do it. And the problem is that it might work,
and most of the time your list might work.
And suddenly something really weird is going
to start happening like maybe you won't be
able to click the item. Maybe you have an
animation in the item that doesn't work anymore.
And the reason for that is that, again, ListView
has many optimizations. It has a very complex
recycler. It makes a lot of assumptions about
the ownership of the views that are on screen.
And to make things even faster is when you
put something in the recycler that view is
not really off screen. Like the view still
thinks it's kind of on screen but the ListView
knows that it's not really the case.
So we handle that very, very carefully. And
again, for performance reasons. And as soon
as you try to play tricks on your adapter,
we are going to end up with views that are
basically zombie views.
For instance, if from the getView method you
return a view that we also have in our recycler,
we are going to have a view that's supposed
to be on screen but at the same time that's
not on screen. So then the framework just
gives up and says, hey, whatever. Like, I
give up.
So just never ever ever ever ever ever do
that.
If you need to access a view directly, we
have a method called get first visible position.
It tells you what is the position in your
adapter of the first view that's visible on
screen. So by using this method and get (inaudible)
account that tells you how many items are
visible on screen, you can easily go back
and forth between the index and the positions.
If you want to for some reason change the
color of a view on screen without doing a
(inaudible) change, just use get child on
the list to get the view that you need.
>>Adam Powell: So finally, after all of this,
I'm sure that we have sort of hammered home
the point. ListView is a really complex widget.
It's probably the most complex one that we
have across the entire Android framework.
We spend a lot of time in there just not only
helping developers but just making sure that
everything stays working, fast, optimized.
And really, it's optimized for repeating unbounded
data.
It adds a lot of complexity to your app.
So if you have a small amount of data that
you just want to have some sort of repeating
presentation for, maybe you don't actually
need a ListView for it at all. Maybe all you
need in this case is to dynamically generate
some views, put them inside a linear layout
with a vertical orientation, and put that
layout inside a scrollView. And this is going
to make your app a lot simpler if you have
a small data set with a bunch of special cases
inside it rather than trying to bend the ListView
into whatever application you have for it.
>>Romain Guy: And that's pretty much it for
today. We could go on for hours about ListView
because there are many features we haven't
talked about. There are many stuff that you
stud know about, but I'm sure by now you are
all pretty bored by ListView.
We are going to start taking questions. If
you want to ask a question you can go to the
microphones in the alleys, and we also have
questions on moderator.
>>Adam Powell: Do we want to bring that up?
>>Romain Guy: Don't be shy. You can come ask
questions.
You can ask about anything you want that's
related to Android.
>>> Hi. You said not to put ListViews in scroll
views. But the assumption behind that was
that the scrollView be vertically scrolling.
If we want to emulate something like the Palm
Pre's pager where we have vertical scrolling
and horizontal paging, I have seen on forums
and stuff that some people are trying to do
that, and that's also been done with Google
sports application. But that particular app,
as far as I can tell, so far is closed source.
But we would like to know how to do that.
>>Romain Guy: So basically, you have vertical
scrolling ListView and you want to go from
page to page horizontally.
>>> I have many pages of similar but different
content --
>>Romain Guy: That's fine. You can use your
horizontal scroll view. What matters is that
the two scrolls that you have on it on the
same axis.
The whole screen, for instance, has a pager
and when you open the folder on home it's
a list, and you can still page horizontally
and scroll that list.
You can look at the source code of the launcher
application.
>>Adam Powell: It's called workspace.java.
>>Romain Guy: It's called workspace.java,
and I think we have that in other applications
somewhere else. But look at workspace.java
in the launch source code and you will see
it's pretty easy to do.
>>Adam Powell: We have had a number of discussions
about specifically adding a widget capable
of doing this horizontal paging into the framework,
and so far we haven't decided on the best
way to do it just in terms of getting it out
there, making sure people are able to make
good use of it.
>>> Excuse me. I have a view in my app that
is -- I try to have been inspired from the
market app the way for an individual app it
has some headers and some little lists inside
it. I thought it was really great.
In implementing that myself without looking
how the market source code did it, it was
really tricky, and it's a little too complicated
for me to want to dot sort of LinearLayout
scrollView. It feels like a ListView, but
in order to do that, I ended up having to
do a lot of Java code. Instead of one larger
XML file, it's a lot of small ones that get
bound together through Java work. I ended
up using a merge adapter, sort of a general
thing which Mark Murphy made which is helpful
for that purpose.
So it's just unifying a lot of different adapters
together.
It just feels like overkill.
Am I missing something on how to do that?
>>Romain Guy: No. That's pretty much the way
to do it.
The big problem, again, is that ListView was
mostly designed to have a long list of data
and every item is pretty much the same.
We do support very different items like you
mentioned.
But, yeah, when you want to do that, unfortunately,
you'll have some work to do.
>>> And the merge adapter itself is really
nontrivial in how it has to track what -- the
position of every item and show the right
one.
It's just something I would never want to
do myself.
But I guess that's just the way it is.
>>Romain Guy: Yeah.
Sorry.
>>> Okay.
>>Romain Guy: But if you have suggestions,
like, I'm sure there are solutions that we
haven't thought of, like, contact us, or file
bugs.
We do look at them.
And we'll see what we can do in a future release.
I'm going to take one of the Dory questions.
So someone, Larry, from China, asks, long
click to get more actions for an item is very
weird for a normal user.
Can we have similar UI widget, like contacts,
action menu, just like Twitter developed by
themselves.
So I think he is referring to that little
popup you get when you click on the contact
in the address book in Android 2.0.
And the answer to that is, yes, sure, you
can have one.
The Twitter app is going to be open source.
So you're going to have the source code for
the widget so you'll be able to use it.
It's actually pretty easy to do.
Maybe it's easy for me to say that because
I know it's done.
But once you see the source code, you'll see
there's no magic in there.
>>> Thanks.
Any tips on how to do an adapter view where
the length of the data set is not known?
>>Romain Guy: Pardon me?
>>Adam Powell: The length of the data set
is not known.
>>Romain Guy: Yeah, actually, that's what
the calendar does.
The calendar, when disturb I think when you
go into the agenda mode, they have basically
an infinite list.
And they do that by just playing with that
change.
So they just say that they have integer at
max value number of items and then they just
populate with number of stuff.
Every time you have a change, you can change
the number of items in the adapter.
You can grab a random number and later on
if you realize you have more items, you can
change that number and keep going.
>>> Thank you.
>>> I noticed when I used bit maps to load
or, like, (inaudible) also that the whole
views have to be refreshed.
Is there any method, like, to say only one
item, one specific item by ID is going to
be changed?
>>Romain Guy: If you are trying to -- so if
you are trying to change one item and you
call notify data set change, the whole view
is going to be refreshed.
But, actually, ListView is pretty smart here,
and this is where we have our complex recycler.
Because it's able to figure out that most
of what you're changing is actually the same
and on screen.
So it's going to reuse everything it can.
It's still going to redraw the entire screen.
But if that's a real issue for you, you can
directly grab the view, you can call get child
at.
And that's why you use get for a visible position,
to figure out what's the translation between
the position and the index, and then you can
just call setImage or whatever you want on
the view.
If you want a good example, if you look at
code.google.com/p/shell, that's the application
that we showed in one of the first slides,
I have very complex code to support that kind
of optimized code, and you can -- optimized
operation, and you can look at it and see
how to do it.
Over there.
>>> Hi.
I have two questions.
First is, we try to use a relative layout
for the list.
And it seems to ignore the attributes not
relative layout.
>>Romain Guy: I know why.
And, actually, I put the answer on one of
the slides.
Yes, so the problem is that you have a relative
layout and your layout attributes are ignored.
It's having very simple.
The documentation for that sucks.
And, again, that's totally our fault.
So I'm very sorry.
So here, for instance, we're calling inflate.
And we're passing null as the last parameter.
Null is the parent -- so that parameter is
the parent of the view you're inflating.
By saying null, you're telling the frame,
I don't know what the parent is going to be.
When we don't know what the parent is, we
don't know what the layout parameters will
be.
So we give up and don't give the parameters.
What we have to do is call this version of
inflate where you pass the parent.
And that's why get view will give you the
parent.
So you pass the parent.
But if you pass true at the end, we're going
to call add view on the parent.
But if you do that on ListView, it's going
to crash.
So you have to pass false.
So whenever you're in getView and you get
something, always pass the parent and.
>>> We also try to use the alpha indexer for
fast scrolling.
And if the data does change, it seems like
the alpha indexer can't be updated.
>>Romain Guy: That's a current limitation.
We have a bug filed somewhere internally about
that.
Maybe we will do it.
But I don't think it's going to happen anytime
soon.
So if you guys want to write a copatch, I'm
going to (inaudible) with myself and I will
be very glad to accept it.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>> You said you were taking questions about
Android in general?
>>Romain Guy: We can try.
>>> Okay.
Well, I'm playing catch-up, because a family
emergency kept me out yesterday.
Has Froyo been addressed or is there word
when it will be?
>>Romain Guy: Nothing has been announced.
>>> Is it true it has hit ASP already, though?
>>Romain Guy: Nothing has been announced?
We are very, very good at dodging those questions.
So don't even try.
The mike first.
Can you grab the mike.
>>> Real quick question.
(Off mike).
>>Romain Guy: So the slides, every session
within the next few weeks will be available
on the Google I/O Web site.
You'll get the video and the slides.
>>> (Off mike).
>>Romain Guy: I don't know.
That's okay.
>>> Okay.
So I have a ListView that part of my apps
-- part of my app is a -- it's a surveying
app, so I'm using GPS between two devices.
So long story is, it takes -- exactly what
it does and what I'm doing that for, I'll
just get right to the point with the ListView
question.
So one of the things is, it -- part of this
is, I'm using SMS to send messages back and
forth.
So somebody can send you their current position,
GPS coordinates, or a message that says, could
you move ten yards to the right or something
like that.
Right now I'm using a Java reg X to sort out
when somebody sends you a pair of GPS coordinates
and populating that in a ListView that has
the positional data, versus the chat window,
which has the ListView.
You were talking earlier about a class which
will do sort of like predictive -- some sort
of sorting out of as you're typing or as the
data comes?
>>Romain Guy: Yeah.
It's filtering.
So if you --
>>> I'm wondering, would the filter be more
appropriate with that or am I just better
off -- is the reg X going to be faster?
>>Romain Guy: I mean, you can implement the
filter with the reg X.
It's really up to you.
I don't think it matters in your case.
>>> I'm not losing or gaining anything just
by going to Java.regX.
>>Romain Guy: Not at all.
>>> Is the filtering mostly for interactive?
Is that mostly for interactive?
>>Romain Guy: Yes.
You can use it for noninteractive actions,
but it's not really meant for that.
>>> All right.
Thanks.
>>Romain Guy: So question from Dory.
So setting the adapter to the ListView can
become a blocking operation if the adapter
gets the data from the network.
Any tips?
Use threads.
That's pretty much all there is to it.
Just don't block the UI thread.
>>Adam Powell: The trick here is to make sure
that even if you're collecting your data from
the network, you have to perform the commit
operation on the UI thread.
So you can go ahead and just post a message
to your UI thread through the normal event
system and take your big blob of data that
you have at the end and go ahead and commit
those changes to the adapter there and call
note tie data set changed.
>>> Hi.
I have a list that I set the list adapter
from an array that I have in my program.
And on click, you know, most of the time,
it works just great.
I have the position.
And then you guys were talking about the filter.
And then there's an ID.
I'm wondering, can I use that ID and will
it correlate to my array in the position it
should be?
Because the position, you know, if there are
filters and then there's three items, 100
items in the array, then it picks the wrong
item.
So can I guarantee that they'll correlate?
>>Romain Guy: So by default, in an array adapter,
the ID is the index of the item inside the
array.
So when you filter the array that you're -- the
IDs will change.
So they are not stable.
So if you want them to be stable across filtering,
you will have to implement your own adapter
and maybe change the filter to store some
extra data in the items so you can know what
item it is.
>>> So I just basically have to cross reference
the data and just check?
>>Romain Guy: Yeah.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>Romain Guy: We know it's not great, but
sorry.
And, unfortunately, we are out of time for
the questions.
So if you have more questions, we have the
Android Google Groups.
There is overflow where you can ask questions
online.
A few of us are monitoring and will try to
answer your questions when we have time.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]